hey everybody what is going on welcome
to another video in this video what
we're going to be talking about is the
labush ray Bing system so I like to go
and look into either Bing or uh trading
or gambling usually they're all one in
the same uh systems and uh especially
the ones that say that they beat the
odds or that they actually profit or
make money and see if if they really do
um and so the Lauser system is the next
one I want to go uh into and the the
claim with this strategy is that you
don't have to win 50% of the time so in
theory you can win say 45% of the time
and you still make a profit now
immediately that should throw up red
flags because it's a progressive betting
system uh and we already know that
Progressive betting systems are uh
somewhat dangerous so we have already
covered a few of the other betting
systems either just straight up
Progressive where we double or nothing
basically or not double or nothing but
uh double up and then when you win you
scale it back uh we've also touched on
the day Allen bear strategy so we've
we've hit quite a few strategies and
found that for the most part there is no
beating the odds um but anyway this
system says that it does not only beat
the odds it will make you money so um
for those who are not familiar with the
uh labush Ray system the idea is that
you set a predefined amount of money
that you want to make beforehand so
let's say we have uh $100 and we want to
make $10 um so just for future reference
that would be a 10% gain that we're
trying to trying to get here so you say
you you predefine your your Wagers
basically so you say like and it needs
to add up to 10 so we'll start with a
wager you know one right and then we'll
do two two so that's five and then we'll
do three uh 6 7
8 right yes uh and then we'll do um
we'll just do a two here okay so let's
just say for the sake of example this is
our setup um and this adds up to 10 and
that would be a win now what we're going
to do is each time we wager uh you wager
your first and your last number it so
you're basically your wagering your
first wager would actually be a three
okay so if you win if you win you would
just knock these off the list right and
you are now up three congratulations if
you
lose uh you lose three and what you end
up doing is you add to the end of the
list what you lost so this was a 1 plus
a two so we add a three to the end of
the list and then what would happen is
our next wager if we were to make
another wager would be a 1 + three not a
plus a two and so we'd wager a four and
if we win it gets knocked off the list
and our next wager would be a two and a
two which would be four and so on and
the idea is you continue wagering until
all of uh your numbers basically get
crossed out and the idea here is if if
that is the case once they are all
crossed out congratulations you made
$10 so now what we want to do is
actually put this into practice and see
like does it actually work and so for
that we're going to use the Python
programming language so we're going to
need a few Imports right out of the gate
we're going to need import random we're
going to need to import time we're going
to need to import map plot lib uh and
that's to obviously graph the results
and then we're going to do from um and
actually we're going to do uh import
matplot li. pyplot as PLT and then from
matplot lib import style so we can make
our grabs look pretty then we're going
to say right away style. use and the
style we're going to use is
ggplot and then um Just for future
reference we're going to basically the
the the fundamental flaw with these
kinds of
strategies um is that if you work it out
on paper and you do say 10 or even a
hundred scenarios you may find that you
uh you won out or you made profit right
you can't test these kinds of strategies
without a program to do it for you
unless you have like a lot of free time
or something and you can sit down and do
like a million sample sizes and just see
like what are the odds really so that's
why we want to use programs obviously so
what this program is going to do is it's
going to run through the strategy
thousand times 100,000 times a million
times so we can actually figure out what
are the true odds so we're going to have
this starting variable broke uncore
count and for now it's going to equal
zero because we haven't lost anything
and then we're going to say we're going
to Define laou
array and this strategy first of all
we're going to go ahead and Global this
broke count
variable and then we're going to say our
starting
underscore funds equals $100 and our
goal equals
$10 then because of our goal we need to
create a system like that system of
numbers that we just made um and this
can be really this is where there's a
degree of uh Randomness to this right so
you could say for example if you want to
make 10 you can do 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
okay so you can bet um and start with 10
ones for example and you can do this any
time so uh this is less risky than the
previous system that we did which was uh
a oops hello uh it was a 1 two two
3 two right so these are our higher
Wagers right and if you lose that means
you even have an an even greater wager
so this system is a little more risky
but it's a little shorter you have less
um less I can't think of the word right
now but uh you're gambling less right
you have less oh my goodness if I can't
think of this word anyway uh I'll think
of it later hopefully anyways um so
we've got this system and then later on
we can maybe test the system uh like
this um and see what if there really is
any difference there uh so the next
thing we're going to have is profit uh
and we're just going to set profit to
equal zero right now I'm going to go
ahead and make some more space here um
and then after profit uh we're going to
say the current funds so we start with
$100 but as we wager and Gamble and all
this we're going to either add funds or
lose funds so current funds uh is just
at first going to equal the same thing
as starting funds and then we're going
to say wager sizes and we're going to
make that an empty array for now or
empty list rather and then plot uncore
funds empty list and then we're going to
say not broke and that is going to equal
true and interestingly enough the the
main main flaw with a lot of these
strategies is that um like the labush
strategy for example you can you can say
I have $100 I want to make $100 right
you can do that um but obviously that
incurs a lot more risk um so a lot of
people tend to do a smaller wager or or
smaller gains and if you remember
anything from like the marting Gale
strategy or um was the other with D
Allen bear strategy the only way that
you could come out on top maybe was
making
astronomically
tiny Wagers right um
so Wagers so small that it was not worth
your time to even be there so um so the
issue with not broke is if you make
Wagers large enough your risk of going
broke is higher and when you go broke
you can't Co back you can't keep
wagering as opposed to when you make
money you keep wagering and this is how
people lose all their money anyways is
because they come in and they keep
winning and they can keep playing while
they're winning and winning feels good
so they keep playing but when you lose
and you go bust and you're broke you are
broke you can't go back with more money
unless you are willing to go into debt
and some people do and obviously that's
a huge problem but um anyway broke so
next we're going to say
wins
um starting with uh I guess we'll say
oops wins uh and we'll say wins
equals cuz later on we're going to do
division here and so we'll just say wins
and loss wins equals ones losses equals
one um and then we're going to say while
profit is less than our goal and we're
not broke so when we reach our goal we
are supposed to stop right for the four
mentioned reasons um we we need to get
out right and I just remember the word
um the word here in if we use this
system we have less exposure right um to
to gambling gambling is risk um so with
this strategy you've got less exposure
than this strategy but you have higher
risk because you have higher wager
amount so you're more likely to very
quickly go bust anyway moving on so
while our profit is less than the goal
right our goal was 10 so while our
profit is not greater than 10 um and
while we're not broke then we can we can
continue wagering so now let go ahead
and set that up and basically we're
going to say if the length of the
system is greater than one and the
reason we have to do this is we keep
knocking things off right um but
eventually like especially with this
system we knock off the one the two the
two the three and we're left with two
and if you recall the way we work this
system is you you wager the first and
the last number um so since this is a
program we have to kind of throw in an
if statement there to handle the fact
that you might not have a first and a
last you might just have a one number um
so if the length of the system is
greater than one our size is going to
equal system the zeroth element which is
like the first element plus
system uh minus one which is the very
last element then we're going to say
wager sizes. append uh and we want to
append size and later on we'll see how
um how much this strategy can escalate
okay so even starting with wager size of
one and one so that's two how how high
does wager size get sometimes and you
might be surprised uh how how high wager
size might go next we're going to do
plot funds. upend current oops current
uncore funds so that was the if
statement right that and that just
basically does our wager um so else you
know else basically pertaining to if the
system is basically length of one we
have one lats offer we're going to say
size equals
system0 and then we're going to say
wager sizes. aend size and then finally
whoops got lost here uh plot funds.
append current
funds so that's our wager now what we're
ready to do is um place the w
right so we're going to say if current
funds is less than or equal to
zero uh not
broke E equals false IE we are
broke and then broke count plus equals 1
so again we're going to run this
strategy across uh multiple instances so
we're going to count how many times we
go broke and how many times we meet our
goal so that's that now uh so if the
current funds less than or equal to zero
L
if uh current uncore funds minus the
wager size is less than or equal to zero
so basically this this asks do we have
enough money to wager both sides so in
theory you could have lost everything
but the strategy is saying or you you
could have let's say $10 left but the
strategy is asking you to wager $20 you
can't wager $20 um so that's basically
what this is asking and the answer to to
that uh would be size equals current
funds so if you're supposed to wager
more than you have um what we're going
to do is just wager everything we have
left uh so the other alternative here
would be to uh either do a resampling so
if you had $20 left it's asking you to
wager $30 what we could do
break down the $20 into another you know
laucher system uh or we could walk away
with those funds something like that uh
but for now we're going to wager them so
size equals current
funds
um and then not
broke um basically at this point we
probably should set not broke to equal
false so we walk away after this point
and then broke underscore counts plus
equals 1 now we're going to go ahead and
say the dice so the dice we're going to
you know base this on on a 100 sided
dice and we're going to roll that Dice
and that will be our 50/50 odds so it's
pretty rare that you get 50/50 odds
anywhere generally they're not that
great um but we're going to play based
on 50-50 odds so just say this we we've
got this so we're going to do random.
Rand range and we want this random range
to go anywhere from 1 to 101 now uh for
anyone who might be confused Rand Rand
range starts at the first number and
goes up to the last number but does not
hit the last number so random. Rand
range is anything from 1 to 100 um in
this scenario so next we're going to say
if dice is less than 51 so if it's 1 to
50 uh what do we want to do we're going
to say that's a loss so losses plus
equals 1 that just adds one to loss then
we're going to system. append size and
what that's doing is adding the loss to
the end of our system so system. append
size and then current funds minus equals
size because we lost so we we subtract
from our funds else congratulations you
won wins plus equals 1 and then we're
going to say profit equals current funds
minus starting fund oops starting funds
so this is our current amount of money
minus the starting amount of money uh
then we're going to go ahead and
do
um and actually I suppose before this is
when you'd want to call we' want to say
uh current uncore
funds plus equals size here and then
we'll calculate profit because at this
point we've already won so calculate the
profit profit equals that and then we
ask a very important question if profit
does not equal
uh the goal so that's what exclamation
mark equal means we're going to try and
we're going to
delete system zero and then we're going
to delete system one uh or rather I'm
sorry negative one so we're removing
those two ends because if we won we
knock them off so try um except uh and
we'll just pass for here uh and that's
if profit equals uh the goal next uh we
are going to let's see current size plus
profit equals and then current funds so
now what we're going to do is if let's
see so if dice
is
uh right so outside of our lse statement
now uh uh we're going
to see we kind of want to calculate
profit here just so we can run this
quick if
statement um but I'm curious
about because you only want to knock
these off if if you won so I suppose it
couldn't hurt I I guess to to
recalculate and in fact what we can do
here is uh let's see losses current
funds equal size so let's copy this and
we'll just paste it here so either in
either system we'll calculate profit um
just in case now we'll come over here
and we're going to say so we're in line
with else so not under that else we're
in line with it um we're going to
actually we're done with else so we're
done being in line with else so uh
delete one step there and now we're
going to do wager sizes. upen
size and then we're going to do plot
funds. append and then current funds so
this is the size of our wager and then
this is our current fund so we can kind
of like watch this as as time goes on um
and we can graph up basically our our
entire performance along the way rather
than just the end so then uh once we've
done that we're going to say S1 and this
will be a subplot one basically S1 plot
w major sizes and then s2.
plot plot buns then we'll come down here
and we're going to say f equals PLT
figure and then we're going to say S1
equals and this will be a subplot f.
addore subplot and we'll just make this
subplot 21 um this is basically these
numbers here just means it's 2 by1 and
this is the first element in that and
then S2 is going to be f. addore subplot
it's again it's a 2x1 but this will be
plot Number
two and then um and then now we're
basically going to ask ourselves like
what kind of sample size do we want
first we'll start with a sample size of
100 just nice and small um then we're
going to say 4X in range of what we're
going to say sample
size um what do we want to do uh so for
X in range of 100 we're going to run
laou so run that function we just
wrote up here okay so we run labush then
um after the end of all of that as
labush runs it adds all of this data
right to everything uh and so at the end
of collecting all of the data total
we're going to print um print
broke
percentage
colon um and this will be the float of
uh broke
count divided by the sample
size uh
times
100.0 now let me do check this real
quick
um hold on see float broke
count
uh okay that should work and then we do
this okay so that will print out our
broke percentage and then we'll do plot.
show so let's save and run
that and here are percentages here our
broke percentage is actually 19% that's
quite High um I'm surprised we got that
um so the let's go back up here real
quick um so the fir the top plot is our
wager sizes and the bottom plot is our
plot funds uh just so everyone is clear
so let's go back up to that so these are
your wager sizes so as you can see if
you recall our system was supposed to be
a small system with Wagers of ones um
but as you can see we get all the way up
to wagering in the 40s uh pretty
crazy um and we can see that our broke
count this is basically our our funds
right so we're trying to get up to about
this Mark right here right the 110 Mark
and we can see quite a few people made
it um the majority of people actually
made it right but 19% of people went
broke and what does that mean though so
uh eight or yeah 81% of everyone made
$10 congratulations so let's say eight
out of 10 people made $10 so that means
you know fund profit let's say so eight
out of 10 people uh made it so that
would be uh $80 basically was profited
but yet uh two out of 10 people lost
$100 so that would be minus 100 or minus
200 rather $200 was lost uh in total so
overall this strategy actually loses
quite a bit of money
um so if you're somebody who goes to the
casino and and Bets using this
strategy wow my dog's like pounding on
the
door yeah if you're someone that goes to
the casino and uses this strategy often
you're going to find that you lose money
now the last thing I want to do is uh
possibly add a bit to this this script
and show you guys a more that exactly
what I was just showing you now just
that we did by hand but we'd want to
actually do it uh Auto automatically so
let's go ahead and uh let me change up a
few things okay so now what we want to
do is we want to step it up a notch
because if you go to the casino with
$100 and you wager five Wagers chances
are you're going to do it again right um
so what we want to do is we want to kind
of add to the strategy a little bit and
so we're going to say we're going to
start with total funded and that's going
to equal zero and then we're going to
say total ending and that's also going
to equal zero uh to start then we're
going to go into our labush Ray strategy
and don't worry this time we'll we'll
test both of these systems just to see
um and we'll also do a higher sample
count because I don't I think 19% loss
was actually uh quite a high number um I
don't think that's supposed to be the
case um so Lauser uh because that's not
statistics what what we should find with
this strategy is when we run it on a
large scale we should find it's about 50
50% and you'll break even but we'll see
I'll be very surprised if we actually
lose money um overall anyway total
funded total ending
um then we're going to come down here
and we're going to go ahead and Global
total funded and Global uh total
ending and uh once we've done that we
want to where is starting funds right so
we have starting
F starting funds is 100 uh and then what
we're going to go ahead and do here is
go total funded plus equals uh starting
funds so each time we run run the lubus
strategy we add the starting funds um to
our total
funded amount and then we come down to
the very very bottom here um
basically uh wager sizes plot funds
current funds we can just put it like
right at the bottom so we'll just say um
total ending total ending um plus equals
current uncore funds so uh as time goes
on each time we start we'll say we add
100 to the total funded and each time we
end we add whatever our ending amount
was to Total ending so at the end of the
day we can say okay well we did a total
of 100 million um dollars right all
together and at the end we ended with a
total of $110 million right we won't but
that is uh what our goal would
be and then we can come down to the very
very bottom here and we can just print
right before here we can just print out
um total funded and then total ending
and I do realize actually now that we
just wrote that we have not used wins
over losses and actually this wins over
losses is um is the problem with this
strategy so we will go ahead and we'll
print and we're going to say
winners um and then wins and I thought
we were going to divide but we're not so
actually I will fix this as well
um
losers I can't remember if we said
losses or what what did we say there
losses um we're starting at one CU I
thought we were going to do division I
didn't want to have a div div by zero
but we not doing that so we'll start at
zero so we've done that again we only
have 100 sample sizes that's okay we
will run that real quick uhoh name wins
is not defined I guess that we did
winners Maybe
uhoh winds equals zero and then at the
very very
[Music]
end I'm surprised it's getting to this
because we should run this
first so in theory we should have
defined
um wins and losses
already uh what we man this is hard um
we can we can maybe we'll get away with
this return wins
losses no that's not going to
work I don't understand because it
should have uh as it goes here it should
Define it I guess it's cuz it's local
variables or something so um what we can
do then is we'll just do exactly what
we've done initially and so we'll go
like this and we'll come up to the top
wins losses like that
and then we will just Global wins Global
losses uh we'll try that again cool so
winners six losers two so initially it
feels like hey well first of all winners
six losers two doesn't make any sense we
should have quite a few more
um anyway that's a problem uh so again
we have our broke percentage more
closely related to what I would expect
is a nine I expect on a large scale
we'll find that our broke percentage is
10 um so this one you can see you know
how many people won how many people lost
obviously we are not calculating wins
and losses
somewhere uh let's
see
if let's see we're trying to
find
[Music]
go so length of system that's fine if
current funds not broke broke count plus
equals 1 losses plus equal
1 uh cuz we went broke
there and
then oh these are like actual dice roll
losses okay we're just going to throw
those out for now the bottom line is you
should see that that this is why the
strategy um is enticing to people
because most people will be winners so
to speak but on a longterm scale you're
a winner of $10 but if you're a loser
you're a loser of $100 okay so that's
that's that's where the strategy gets
people uh so sample size 100 um and then
so let's go ahead and run this more time
so this one starting funds was $10,000
awesome ending funds
$108 so as we can see on a long-term
scale we made
$8 so let's go ahead and close this and
we'll now say our sample size is
1,000 uh eventually we'll have to take
away the graph because this is going to
take a long time um but now we've seen
that okay we have a sample size of now a
th000 people so that means we have
100,000 and our so starting amount was
100,000 ending amount 99,5 A8 and we can
see all these poor souls down here
losing all their
bank and then um so that was a th000 so
we could maybe get a away with 10,000
before we turn this thing headless
um we'll see if it's going to plot this
but um the other thing you can do too is
we can take away the plot and you can
add a sample size of a million and you
really should find that about 10% of the
time you lose and what ends up happening
is so you make $100 right so you win 10
times and then you lose your $100 and
what you're left over with is uh you've
broken even um so here we go again broke
percentage 10.66 again your broke
percentage should be about
10% um because you're risking $10 out of
your
$100 every time and so your broke
percent's going to be 10 and what ends
up happening is you lose that one out of
10 times and you lose
$100 um so I hope what is taken away
from this is 5050 odds this graph is too
heavy 5050 odds
really means 50/50 because at the end of
the day you'll make $100 but then you'll
lose $100 um and you'll find that you've
broken completely even but the downside
is you've broken completely even and
you've taken on risk um and so you could
be one of these people who was trying to
make $10 but they risked $100 to make
$10 and instead they lost everything and
so it's just not really worth it and we
can see that actually we're not breaking
even even
we're not even breaking even anyway
we're not even breaking even we're
losing money overall so you're actually
more of a loser it's just sad because
only 10% of those people that play are
losers in theory um but if you play the
strategy enough you you must become one
of those people and you lose a lot more
than you're wagering so anyways that's
the labush system I had a lot of fun uh
testing that I couldn't believe it when
I was reading it and so I just had to go
ahead and run run through it it's
surprising to me how uh I mean I guess
it's the internet but how people can
just say that this strategy will make
you money you don't even have to win 50%
of the time to to profit but they don't
actually run through the statistics um
which clearly shows that you lose money
um there's no question about it you
can't avoid 50/50 odds you just can't uh
it's just not possible really so
anyway um so that's it with this video
if you have any questions or comments I
I it's totally possible I coded
something flawed in here our wins and
losses was clearly a problem that's why
we just got rid of it at the end um but
you can at least see with a percentage
that uh we have a very small percentage
of losers but obviously those losers
lost a lot of money so anyways uh if you
do have any questions or comments if I
did something wrong or uh you want to
see a different strategy whatever please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time